hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome to episode 49 of game
programming so today we're going to take
a look at flipping sprites um loot last
episode I asked you guys and you said
that you wanted me to show you how to
flips price a little bit just deal with
that now I'm not sure if we'll actually
implemented into the game there's no
real point like it's not enough sped
ending up we might as well we'll see you
know we'll see um I was quickly up not
my stiff okay
so um we've got this bright as you guys
know yeah you guys know this you guys
know this but I like me anyway huh um
okay here we go
so King Jonah right over here whoops
don't worry Ron King Jenna we've got
like this right which we really don't
need so I'm going to go ahead and get
rid up actually I'm gonna go one step
further and just make it all nice I
think yeah all right there we go
Jenna just got deleted part of him did
um okay I'll say that there's obviously
a lot of ways to do this but let's just
deal with it the normal way so um first
off you'll actually see that if I try
and run this right now what we're going
to get is who you are live here if we go
left
we're just gonna get this instead of um
the in Jonas right but um that's alright
if we go into um let's just ignore that
for a minute let's just try and flip
this one so what we're trying to flip
this one yet to basically be you don't
like the other way around to face right
no sorry to face left it's currently
facing a ride we want to face left so if
we come over here into our screen cloths
this is what the whole like this is what
the whole like precept basically is here
if we go into our screen class we're
actually already in Astra and our screen
class we've got this thing our to be
here we're rendering the player right
that is the method that we're calling to
actually render the player there's all
the code for it now this this cul it's
kind of hard to coal coal come anyway
this um this variable which stands for
color really that variable it actually
takes these bright pixels it takes the
appropriate location with spry pixels
and it actually you know
in the end if it's not pink it actually
renders them now
the thing is the way that it sort of
cycles through these pixels it is it
goes you know xx as you can see over
here it's equal to zero and it goes all
the way up to 31 right just less than
theta to 31 and the way that does is it
is going to left to left to right so in
other words it's doing it from 0 to 31
now what if we want to do it the other
way around what if we flip it what if we
say you know what instead of doing it
that way let's let's do it in reverse
order right let's do the X pixels in
reverse order so instead of telling from
left and going to rice tiles from the
right and go to the left so let's take a
look at that I'm going to make a
variable here called access and this
just stand for X sprite okay and I'll
just make that equal to X now so if we
actually just replace this with excess
and just for all intents purposes I'll
make the wires variable as well we'll
just have it right now and we'll make
this YS okay all right cool so now what
I can do is actually instead of actually
having X here because right now it's
just equal to X and if we run this well
obviously get the same result that we
always do
now what if I subtract 31 right or are
not really subtracting 31 but subtract X
from 31 right have a think for a moment
about what that does okay it's pretty
cool so what I can do now is I'll open
this up and then wow look at that we
flipped a sprite how does that work well
let's talk about that right now first
thing you realize is the actual value of
this variable so the reason is 31 first
of all are not 32 is because as I
mentioned whoa there we go
I don't like hit controls that asynch
doesn't seem to do something else but
I'm okay so why is it 31 or 32 it's 31
because of what I explained here right
we start at 0 and we get to when X is
less than 32 and in other words what
that means is X actually goes up to 31
and then this condition is no longer you
know can't go up to 32 because otherwise
you
wouldn't be true right so that's why
it's 31 because it goes from zero all
the way up to 31 not from 1 to 32 that
would be 32 values it goes from zero
inclusive to 31 so that's 32 values and
all that's the size of our sprite
that's why 30 wants him now minus X what
does that do so basically what that does
and the best way to probably show you
guys is by doing it this way
opening paint on that so we've currently
got a sprite and I'm gonna just quickly
make sure that we actually do have a
sprite so 32 by 32 one nice sprite and
we'll probably just I don't know let's
just I'll just use this this tool to
sort of explain what I mean when we
start over here you usually how we do
sprites is we start at zero right which
is this this like row right here and
then we sort of go on to we sort of go
on to like onto one that's one right
then we're going to like two and then we
go on to three and we sort of keep going
like that until we hit 31 which is right
over here that's how we read through
sprites now what what we're suggesting
here is it instead of actually going 0 1
0 1 2 3 all the way up to 31 we actually
start at 31 minus X and what does that
mean
that means that when X is equal to 0 the
value is 31 so we actually start at 31
and then when X is 1 its 31 minus 1 so
it's 30 and so we go down a bit right
and we keep doing that
you know until we get down to 0 again
which is when 2 when X is 31 so 31
months 31 is 0 right that makes sense so
what we're doing essentially I love
saying that word as you guys know is
instead of going from this way to this
way
horrible low-resolution we're actually
going from this way to this way so we're
just simply reversing it literally and
that is how that works now that works
both ways so what we can do is actually
um if I figure out a good way to
actually show this impact on that
powering on yeah looks like on to that
um I was gonna hmm I was going to here
we go um rotate 90 degrees yay
okay so this is how it works for Y right
we usually go from top to bottom but
what if we go from bottom to top all
right
what if we do that what if we what if we
hit up a 31 minus y now if we do that
look at that King sure knows upside down
bro how sick is that so that's that's
how we can do that and obviously we
don't have to do this at all we're to do
sort of one of the things which is like
that so in other words it's not flipping
X anymore but yeah that's sort of
housewife living west so it's um it's
pretty cool it's very simple concept
it's really easy to implement and now
you guys are kind of going to decide how
to pop it in right because what we've
done now is we've got like a permanent
thing we want to somehow control if we
flip a lot so in other words the way I
usually do it is I usually make an
integer called flip you guys might be
like why's it an integer wise or not a
boolean and there isn't it's an integer
I like to have it as an integer is
because um we can we obviously flip in
one there's four different states it can
be on nothing flipped X flipped Y
flipped or both flipped
that's four different states so if you
really want it to right this is up to
you of course like there's there's
millions of ways to Department up
millions but there's a lot of ways to do
everything in programming which is why
you know the way I'm doing it doesn't
necessarily reflect the best way to do
it's just how I want to do it and it
does work obviously you could make two
boolean's one for X live and why flip
before they're both true the newer flip
both if one of them is true for that one
if they're both false and if anything
but um that's I don't know I don't
really like that parameter too much so
um
have an integer called flip and that
seems to work out pretty well so in
other words what I'll do here is I'll
say that if if flip is equal to one
sorry 2 then we'll flip Y or sorry or
flip is equal to 3 which is both so 2 is
2 equals what is it what is wrong with
this syntax error what I've done is a
bracket somewhere if flip equals to or
what died I died mr. bragin someone huh
that was weird anyway if if flip equals
2 so 2 is going to equal flip y and 3 is
going to equal flip both right so in
other words if this statement is true
for X which is right over here
then I'm you know if it's one which is
flip X or if it's three which is for
both then yeah flip it but otherwise
we'll just keep you know access and YS
as it's supposed to be so in other words
what that means right what that means is
um is what that mean that means that if
flip is equal to zero it's just going to
ignore both those things now obviously
we can't just simply do that you can see
access and wires aren't being declared
here and we can fix that pretty easily
by simply making an integer up here you
know called wire set it equal to wife
now and then if if need be we'll change
it to that
right simple that's usually how I handle
flipping then again I'll just make you
can do it whatever way works for you you
don't have to have to do it at all like
this by that I provided with you guys
that Andy wall made that was um
else fine so there we go that's sort of
how I roll
that's I've shown our rolls so you don't
you can do it this way it's good what's
a pretty good way to do it I like to
think but um but yeah anyway so one more
thing we'll do quickly it's going to be
quite a long episode but um one thing we
can do it quickly is when we render play
here the flip can really put on a few
things so I like to make a variable game
called flip if Direction equals pre we
don't really have a player
anymore so play our side I might change
it to right so whoops play it change it
to side and I just hit sorry I did that
by hitting alt shift ah
and that actually refractors it yep okay
there we go um or you could just hit
right-click refactor and then rename and
that'll I should rename it everywhere so
who actually go to the right class you
can see that I'm it renamed it here as
well play aside so we can delete player
left now and simply over here will say
that if Direction equals that or direct
Nichols going left which is that way
then which like that thing and finally
one thing that we need to do is I if we
just put another one hand here
so if Direction equals three then I'm
just thinking is that a good way house
it's not necessarily another probably
probably kind of redundant so we could
just say here that if Direction equals
three then you know if flip equals which
one always with one yeah otherwise five
equals zero so int flip equals zero and
we obviously I need this then I'm trying
to think yeah that'll be fine I guess
just do it this way
all right so let's test that out real
quick and there you go so we have we
have awesome flipping there is a bit of
crown movement here because my crown is
so bigger than belly carrier but I would
probably fix that up in paint.net I
already closed yeah I already closed
that one open with paint.net and a
common problem sometimes is that it's
not exactly in the middle but it does
seem to be I don't know if it will help
yeah okay it looks like it's in the
middle so that'll be fine
um I'm not gonna bother with that now
but yeah there's your little flipping
and we're using the same sprite for both
sides so yeah anyway hope you enjoyed
this episode of game programming if you
did please hit that like button and I'll
see you guys see you guys in episode 50
that's gonna be a big episode I can tell
you that right now actually well big
episode in the sense that it's a big
number not really there's gonna be super
long but yeah anyway thanks for watching
guys see you later bye
you